well the hyde park shopping center it's
getting a makeover yeah the old retail
site on charleston and arville is known
for renting to longtime businesses like
flex nightclub and collectible kingdom
mary jane bellissa tells us what will
become of the historic plaza
those who work and live near the hyde
park retail area on charleston and
arville are reminiscing of what it once
was it's kind of sad because i grew up
there but i'm excited to see what it
becomes and what new buildings are going
to be made and what it will become with
mcneil and all the people around there
we need more community in that area and
so bringing small businesses together to
bring that i think will be huge janice
carpe and her family has owned the
historic marketplace since the 1960s
from welcoming the first kfc in nevada
to housing local staples like bill's
auto radio and flex nightclub this used
to be a really great shopping center we
had you know great tenants but as the
years went on the property fell into a
little bit more disrepair carpe says
redevelopment has been years in the
making working with gatsky real estate
and sr construction to revamp the site
it's going to be a modern day retail
shopping center that's going to bring in
new businesses and new jobs you see it
coming down charleston but there are an
awful lot of blighted properties and
this one this one has needed needed to
go for a long time flex nightclub is the
first building to be demolished after
they temporarily closed down in january
demolition for the entire plaza is
expected to take up to two weeks carpe
is hoping to add a fast food joint and
other needed shops she is open to taking
in new tenants and old ones it's
possible that flex night club will come
back and they were interested in the
corner area back there which would give
them more space we love this area we
feel a real loyalty to this area mary
jane baleza live local now